ON, 12 TIMES.
SHAQ, I PROMISE YOU, YOU PLAYED
WITH ME, YOU WOULD HAVE SHOT 35.
I WOULD HAVE GOTTEN YOU THE
SHOTS.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE BIG FELLAS
FREE THROW PERCENTAGE IS MUCH
BETTER AND WE ARE GOING TO --
>> I SAW IT IN THE BACK EARLIER.
>> WE ARE GOING TO ALLOW YOU TO
REDEEM YOURSELF AND LOOK AT THE
BACK BOARD HERE.
HE HAS THE LOGOS OF THE TEAMS
YOU PLAYED FOR.
>> I'M NOT SURE --
>> FROM YOUR --
>> NO, NO, THERE'S A LINE.
RIGHT FROM THERE.
>> THE LINE, RIGHT THERE.
>> LOOK AT THE REBOUND.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF THEM.
>> WHERE'S THE LINE?
>> RIGHT HERE, THIS LINE.
>> YEAH, YEAH, LET'S GO.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
>> HAVE YOUR CHOICE.
>> YOUR CHOICE OF BALLS.
>> THIS ONE.
>> YOU DON'T WANT THIS ONE?
>> I WILL TAKE THE LITTLE BALLS.
>> HERE'S THE QUESTION.
HERE'S THE QUESTION.
HOW MANY ATTEMPTS WILL IT TAKE
BEFORE HE HITS ONE?
>> HITS ONE?
>> LESS THAN FIVE.
>> LESS THAN THREE.
>> LESS THAN FIVE
>> I WANT SAY THREE.
>> WAIT, FROM THERE?
>> NO, THIS LINE.
>> MAYBE FIVE, MAYBE FIVE.
>> I WOULD SAY, OVER FIVE.
>> OVER FIVE.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS GOING TO
BE THAT FAR AWAY.
>> 0 FOR 2.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> IN THE HOUSE OVER HERE.
>> STOP MOVING IT, MAN.
>> THE HOUSE IS SHAKING IT.
>> SHAKE THAT.
>> THAT WAS 0 FOR 3.
>> OVER FIVE.
>> HEY, DON'T WORRY, SHAQ.
>> REMEMBER TO PLAY FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER TO PLAY FAN DUEL'S
OVER/UNDER GAME.
IT'S 0 FOR 4.
>> HOLDUP THE EPISODE OF LAW AND
ORDER.
>> 0 FOR 5.
>> 0 FOR 6.
THERE YOU GO.
>>.
>> MAN, I'M ABOUT TO KILL TWO
PEOPLE ON LAW AND ORDER.
JUST DUNK.
>> NO, DON'T, HE WILL BREAK THE
PLEXIING, 1 FOR 8, VERY NICE.
>> NOT BAD.
>> JUST MESSING WITH Y'ALL.
THAT WAS ENTERTAINING.
I KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
DON'T BREAK IT.
>> I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
>> NO, NO, COME HERE.
>> I WILL CALL YOU.
>> QUIT MESSING AROUND.
THAT'S A WRAP FOR "INSIDE THE
NBA" PRESENTED BY KIA.
OH!
FOR CHUCK AND SHAQ AND FOR
KENNY, WE ACTUALLY HAVE A FEW
DAYS OFF HERE.
>> YES.
>> HEY, SHACK WITH THE -- DON'T
RUN IT, HELP ME, KENNY.
HELP ME, PLEASE SAVE ME, KENNY.
>> STAY AWAY FROM WILD LIFE.
>> HOLD ME DIESEL.
>> DON'T JOKE ABOUT SNAKES, MAN.
>> THANKS AGAIN TO THE BUCKS
CIRCUS FOR COMING BY AND
ENTERTAINING US WITH THE PYTHON.
>> AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> I DROPPED SOMETHING OVER
THERE.
>> OH, HE MISSED IT.
>> YES, HE DID.
>> OH, AND NOT BUT I THINK HE
WAS FOULED, SEND HIM TO THE
LINE.
WE GOT A PLAYOFF D